alien's killing it let's hear it for
melee ashley
bailey and ashley shiori he's doing an
excellent job okay
yeah i quite enjoy long flights
to the audience you just went i quite
enjoy long flights
how could anyone enjoy long flights well
what would you enjoy
are you in like economy when you're
running around all the time
and what are you a peasant
that did sound a bit aggressive
no because in my mind i don't enjoy like
i only fly economy and i don't enjoy
that [ __ ] yeah i feel like when you
if someone says i enjoy flying my first
immediate thought is ah emirates first
class yeah
yeah yeah exactly exactly yeah
is you know being the people we are
right business
busy schedules busy lives yeah lots of
getting up
running around the place tokyo trains
hectic hectic hectic
get to the airplane no choice but to
just
sit there right now nine hours that's
great
and watch a damn movie right right
so what's great about that because it
means i'm not running around like a
cycle no
i do agree that it's quite relaxing
cause it's like the one time that you
like
disconnect from the world
actually like since they started
introducing wi-fi to planes
i actually don't like it no because the
worst part is that it's not even good
enough so it's just good enough where
you can maybe load a tweet after
refreshing like 10 years yeah
so get your hope up you pay 20 bucks for
it and it's [ __ ] no no i completely get
like the whole like disconnecting from
the internet thing because like i
remember like one time
i flew the one time i flew business in
my life i was like oh
i get wi-fi and it's fast enough to load
youtube
hell yeah all i'm going to do is watch
youtube in the end i slept for half of
it yeah
that's very comfortable yeah yeah right
people get it to sleep
right right yeah but i was like oh no
i'm gonna be in the most comfortable
position watching all the youtube i want
and there'll be no distractions
whatsoever i think i watched it for like
two hours and i was like sleeping i'm
gonna sleep i don't know what it is
about plane but
for me sleeping on a plane is like
nearby impossible
like there's just like they i can't i
can't know how you sleep with your
physique
i have trouble not finding space on like
on like a plane seat as enough
as it is yeah you must scare everyone
when you walk on that plane everyone's
like [ __ ]
please i hope he's not next to me
lady yeah yeah yeah she's going to be
like tiny if there's a if there's a
massive dude on this side see next
you're like well [ __ ]
rip armrest that armrest is going to him
not me
so the moment i ask you to move to go to
the toilet i've made like a [ __ ]
scene
it's
next time you catch a plane you could
try reading a book
another thing you could do on a plane
that's that's that's what i do though
it gives me plenty of time to read a
book this sounds like right like you
know one of those very pandering things
like 10 things you can do on a platform
have you ever heard of one of those
before life hacks 10 things you can do
um books
contain a wealth of knowledge
access during your nine hours of sitting
do you read a lot of books i do now i
never did before
but it was about halfway through 2019
i suddenly became a workaholic why i
don't know
something snapped well i was i was um
doing
lots of shows in china at the time and
so i was back and forth back and forth
back and forth it's funny because
everyone on the management team is like
well it's you know it's just it's just
like a three-hour flight
it's nice and close so just it takes all
day yeah
right so you see three hour flight but
going to the airport alone it's like a
two three hour yeah
go on to the airport then you know get
to the airport go through all that at
the airport then the flight then get
off the plane or stuff the airport then
get to wherever you're going it's
like a holiday for sure um
and uh so i just spent so much time
on the planes i've watched through all
the movies of interest
and you know they only refresh them once
every two months or something right
sometimes you watch a jason statham film
i watched plenty of those i love statham
he's a great man
he's fast and furious but um i watched
through all of those and so
and so i switched to podcasts for a
while some dally podcasts and i'm just
hey next time you catch a plane
don't forget to download trash taste
first so
i went through that and podcasts are
kind of good because you kind of fall
asleep with them and then wake up and
you kind of
still know what's going on but i got to
a point when my ears were sore
from the things in them too much
yeah so i discovered the magic of books
[Laughter]
did you know that before podcasts
existed people read these things called
books